bonsoir une chaise à nova merci d'être
avec nous nouvelle journée mouvementée
on disait pour manuel macro on se
demande quand cela va s'arrêter quelle
est la chose qui pourrait stopper cet
engrenage
c'est très clair l'élection d'un nouveau
président serait quelque chose qui
stopperait cet engrenage mais il faut
attendre trois ans on ne voit pas
comment les choses pourraient se dénouer
sans qu'il y est un geste significatif
de la part du président vous savez la
politique le gouvernement des hommes ce
n'est n'est une science ni une technique
c'est un art et la figure du l'éléphant
dans le magasin de porcelaine si elle
donne l'impression que l'éléphant a une
grande force
elle ne va pas résoudre la question de
savoir comment on va dîner et là on voit
que la transigeant ce qui a été opposé
aux divers grévistes et où diverses
professions a conduit par exemple
aujourd'hui les personnels des
transports publics à suspendre leur
grève après 45 jours
l'élément qui avait justifié sa était la
suspension de l'âge pivot est à 64 ans
et on annonce aujourd'hui que l'âge
déquilibre qu'il remplace est à 65 ans
c'est une façon d'armes est une sorte de
dispositifs parce que nous sommes en
france qui est un pays éruptif dont on
voit mal comment il ne va pas surgir par
pousser un peu comme la vapeur sort
d'une marmite
chaque fois que le coup lève le
couvercle se soulève la vapeur va sortir
chaque fois que le président la sortie
et on peut penser que le sentiment que
45 jours de grève n'ont pas même obtenu
une forme de négociations vont donner le
sentiment à des minorités agissantes que
seule une action violente va pouvoir
faire bouger les lignes
vous êtes une minorité il s'agit de cela
on a vu la tentative d'intrusion dans un
théâtre parisien où emmanuel macron
assister à une pièce ce début d'incendié
face au saccage en tout cas de la
brasserie la rotonde quelle est votre
analyse
la grève se murant violence et la suite
entre guillemets logique
vous savez dans une société quand le
volume global des tensions est très
élevé ou trop élevés comme il l'est
aujourd'hui on a toujours un moment une
plaque sensible
un groupe de gens qui se trouve placée à
un endroit particulier qui ressent un
peu plus la violence de la situation et
qui va s'exprimer d'une manière violente
de façon inattendue et imprévisible
c'est ça la grande difficulté c'est le
caractère imprévisible et inattendu de
bouffées de violence qui peuvent
survenir quand une société atteint un
degré de pression très élevé et après 45
jours de grève sont négociations sans
succès avec un durcissement même de la
position officielle de l'exécutif on on
est dans les conditions qui favorisent
ces explosions c'est surgissement on
peut penser que jusqu'à la fin de son
quinquennat
emmanuel macron aura des difficultés
chaque fois qu'il aura sorti il n'y a
pas que malienne macro et aussi la cfdt
qui est la cible de quelques violences
nouvelle intrusion aujourd'hui au siège
de la cgt menée par une quinzaine de
personnes encagoulées qui ont coupé
l'électricité pendant quelques minutes
une action d'ailleurs revendiquée par
les syndicats cgt énergie l'île de
france est ce que la violence est
devenue une forme d'action de mode
d'action normale entre guillemets
banalisée dans notre société aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on exagère cgc à faire
quelques militants d'un autre syndicat
honte dans un syndicat pour dire leur
protestation ou ce pas très bien on va
et ils n'ont pas détruit
ils n'ont pas cassé ils ont arraché ni
les mains nez les yeux on est en face de
quelque chose qui n'est pas
violence à force ouverte alors que on
peut se trouver dans les mois qui
viennent face à des actions à force
ouverte et qui ne viseront pas la cfdt
je crois vous pensez que la situation va
aller de mal en pis y est ça va empirer
or vous jusqu'où il n' est que s'il n'y
a pas quelque chose qui soit ressentie
par la majorité de la population qui a
soutenu le mouvement gréviste et qui a
pensé pour 75 % d'entre elles et qu'il
fallait que le gouvernement modifie sa
copie s'il n'y a pas une forme de
réponse à ces 75 % 2
jean on peut penser que la tension ne
sera pas porté par les 75% mais elle
sera portée par des secteurs plus
restreint mais cependant suffisamment
large pour que toute sortie à quelques
moments que ce soit se heurte à ces
incidents
on peut imaginer que l'exécutif a le
raisonnement que la montée aux extrêmes
permet de mettre en scène le duel
habituel qui rend invincible
l'opposant de marine le pen ça n'est pas
si simple
et ce serait un calcul erroné que de
jouer la politique du pire comme il
semble qu'à l'heure actuelle les
stratèges de l'élysée ait choisi de le
faire pour vous c'est une vraie ce
trajet stratégie de la part du
gouvernement ce qui est en train de
passer ce n'est pas tout simplement de
l'improvisation et voilà une manière de
mener notamment cette réforme des
retraites de manière improvisée et non
maîtrisée
c'est une stratégie voulue de jouer le
pourrissement de jouer cette violence
qui manque finalement il de la
maintenance si j'ose dire
on peut penser qu'il y aille au départ
beaucoup d'approximations avec le fait
qu'on change le responsable du dossier
en cours de route que les projections
étaient embêtés par quelques
affirmations de la voir voilà que les
projections n'avait pas été fait
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé en disant
que jamais il accepterait d'âge pivot le
premier ministre a présenté un âge pivot
à 64 ans puis a retiré l'âge pivot de 64
ans pour en remettre à 65 ans de ce
point de vue on n'a pas l'habitude sous
la vème république de cet aspect
brouillon de l'exécutif mais de l'autre
côté on voit bien qu'il y à cette
tentation dans une partie
ceux qui sont aux affaires de penser que
la politique de la tension va permettre
de garantir un second quinquennat
je ne le crois pas je crois qu'elle va
garantir que la tension va s'affirmer
s'affermir et au total augmenté le degré
de violence dans une société c'est
toujours un risque parce qu'on ne sait
jamais comment revenir en arrière
vous êtes un fin connaisseur de la vie
politique et de l'histoire de la vie
politique française
est ce que finalement cette situation on
l'a déjà connu
non même en mai 68 avec le charles de
gaulle ni n'était pas attaqué de la
sorte le général de gaulle non ce ne se
présentait pas comme ça d'abord son
premier ministre georges pompidou
dès qu'il est rentré de roumanie où il
était temps en voyage officiel à faire
rouvrir la sorbonne a donné une série de
concessions aux étudiants mais c'était
trop tard
un certain nombre de salariés s'étaient
eux-mêmes mis en grève sur d'autres
thèmes et d'autres sujets immédiatement
des négociations ont été ouvertes
le smic a été montée de 370 à 600 francs
c'est à dire une hausse extraordinaire
il a été décidé une hausse générale des
salaires de 10%
donc c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
significatif dans les résultats d'une
part et d'autre part une négociation
était engagé dès le départ là nous
n'avons jamais eu de négociations les
événements de mai 68 il démarre vers le
huit ou neuf mais il se termine autour
du 1er ou 2 juin nous voyons là que du
sun décembre au 20 janvier
c'est beaucoup plus long que mai 68
merci beaucoup gildas casanova d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
vous avoir apporté votre analyse